there are new signs that america is
moving in the right direction
against the coronavirus the first
shipments of the new single-dose johnson
and
johnson and johnson vaccine could arrive
in hospitals later today
more than 50 million americans have
already received at least one dose of
the pfizer and moderna vaccines
and that includes at least 41 million in
just a month of february alone
covet cases are falling in the u.s
averaging around 66
000 a day over the past week it's a rate
we have not seen since the month of
october
however the cdc warns that it is still
too many
errol barnett is in louisville for us
against site of a massive effort to ship
the single dose vaccine out to americans
we're in a race here arrow
how long could it take
that's right tony good morning well
those doses should be arriving
in the next few hours ups telling cbs
news
they've shipped 140 000 of the johnson
johnson vaccines
overnight of course they expect those
numbers to creep
up all week as these deliveries continue
the aircraft the cargo jet you see
behind me
just one of the many planes that's part
of this gargantuan effort
ups and fedex trying to get 4 million
vaccines out
to those who desperately need it
signed sealed and out for delivery
the third coronavirus vaccine beginning
its long journey
monday here at the ups healthcare
command center in louisville
brian thomas's team is tracking vaccines
across the u.s
and europe people should realize as you
take possession of this new vaccine
you're still
distributing the two previous vaccines
absolutely and so
while we're excited to have the new
volume come on board and that
represents another provider we
absolutely can't lose
track in sight of all of the other
responsibilities we have for the
existing two providers
of the nearly four million doses going
out this week 2.8 million will go to
states
eight hundred thousand for retail
pharmacies and another one hundred
sixty thousand for community vaccine and
federally qualified health centers
some of those vaccines will end up here
in midland michigan
in the care of dr richard bates cbs news
spoke with him in january about his
weekly trips north
loading his truck with a cooler of
vaccines
driving them roughly three hours to one
of michigan's most geographically
isolated hospitals in rural alpena
he's excited about the potential impact
of johnson johnson's
one-shot vaccine for that community
we're in alpena we're not talking about
freeways
so we're talking about uh you know
two-lane roads
uh dirt roads sometimes it's hard to get
people
for the first dose and then to ask them
to come back that can be quite a
challenge
and because this new vaccine can be kept
in standard refrigerators
bait says eventually it could be shipped
directly to rural healthcare providers
i think that's going to be more
accessible and i won't have to be in the
transport business
now bates also tells cbs news he
believes mid michigan
health expects to receive its first
johnson and johnson
doses later this week they're aiming to
vaccinate homebound individuals for whom
a visit to the clinic
is really tough as well as recently
discharged patients
also migrant workers anthony dr richard
bates playing a key transport role there
along with ups and fedex
thanks harold absolutely